fans and critics alike have already
started to weigh in on Adam warlock's
looks in the Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 trailer here's how he Stacks up to his
comic book counterpart
the long-awaited debut of the Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 movie trailer has
finally come and has already garnered
millions of YouTube views and there are
a lot of revealing bits of the story
packed into just under two minutes
there's a strong hint that many of the
main characters will meet a fatal end
and the introduction of Lila a fan
favorite character from the comics but
the debut of another comic book
character that fans have been waiting
for since Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2
debuted in 2017 is probably the biggest
reveal that character is none other than
Adam Warlock played by Will Poulter
think I shall call him
Adam
there's a ton of hype for the film as a
whole but the chatter around warlock is
particularly positive many fans are
eager for the emotional payoff they've
been waiting almost six years for what
they may not know however is that
adapting warlock from the comics in a
way that would please moviegoers and
comic book fans alike as a tall ask
thanks to his many rebirths in the
comics Adam Warlock has had more costume
changes than even the most seasoned
X-Men veteran from the brief look we get
it's clear that warlock will be wearing
his red uniform with a skull affixed to
the collar this is the costume he wore
after being resurrected to defeat Thanos
and protect half of all life in the
universe from being blinked out of
existence by The Infinity Gauntlet it
makes sense that the studio would go
with this look since that's also the arc
where he has the most interaction with
nebula Gamora and Drax all of whom will
be returning for Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 3. so far the vast majority of fans
are in favor of this Choice several
redditor think the makeup has improved
since the last film and although other
commenters didn't see much of a
difference at all they agree it looks
good and fits well with the Sci-Fi tone
of the film but not everyone is as
optimistic even though there's a ton of
praise for warlock's split second
appearance in this appreciation thread
for the trailer one user said I feel
like they could punch up the color on
those costumes a bit but the top comment
from Reddit expressing enthusiasm for
warlock's presence in the trailer has
hundreds of upvotes so far so it's safe
to assume that the look he'll be
sporting in the MCU will go over well
with the majority of audiences those who
have viewed the trailer saw warlock for
no more than a second and in that brief
amount of time all we see is a brief
shot of his face from the shoulders up
as well as him seemingly punching a
downed nebula hard in the head if you
pay close enough attention you can see
the skull decoration on the movie
version of his suit albeit it's muted to
blend in rather than standing up
prominently as it does in the comics
he's also sporting a very powerful soul
German is for him and it does appear as
though he still has his red cape bands
and critics alike are impressed with how
warlock looks in the trailer prominent
movie critic Tessa Smith at Rotten
Tomatoes in a longer tweet about the
overall impression the trailer made on
her said I'm not ready to say goodbye to
these guys but can we talk about how
incredible Adam Warlock looks with the
warm reception warlock has received so
far it would be a surprise if fans ended
up hating him after seeing him make his
big MCU debut in theaters next year
foreign